So, Nicodemus was talking to Jesus,
right? And there's two things that he
said that stand out to me. Number one,
to see and enter the kingdom of God, you
must be born again.
>> That's what he said.
>> So, the average Jehovah Witness says,
"We're not, bro. So, we can't even see
nor enter the kingdom of God."
>> And now, I'll tell you another problem I
have with the Watchtower that kind of
messed me up. Johannes Griber, have do
you know who that is?
>> No.
>> So, here's the thing about him. When
they searched out translators who
translate John 1:11 particular, they
admit that he was an oultist. Anybody
with any sense of spirituality who love
for God or Jesus is not going to be okay
with that. Somebody said that our
version of like communion was basically
like a satanic ritual because they read
from the scriptures out loud of Jesus'
command to eat and drink. And yet we
openly and publicly take that bread,
look at it, reject it, and don't
partake, and pass it to the next person.
And when I read that comment, I sat
there and thought, "Is this really what
I've been doing?" Where I thought that
I've been honoring Jesus this whole
time. I'm trying to repent of the life
that I've lived. But because I'm so
indoctrinated, brother, I am so taught
like I'm telling you, it is I was at
school when I was a kid being like, "You
got to be a Jehovah's Witness or you're
going to die." you know, like
>> what's uh what's your religion?
>> I am a Jehovah's Witness. I was baptized
when I was 16 years old and I'm 30 now.
So,
>> I believe Jesus is Jehovah. What do you
think?
>> You know, man, if you would have asked
me that 5 years ago, I might have
disagreed with you. But
>> there's been a lot of there's been a lot
of evidence that I've seen and I can
kind of I can actually argue and make a
defense for it both ways. So I can kind
of I can see it where even when I talk
to our own elders and stuff, they can't
see it. For me, what matters the most is
I know Jehovah to be the most high true
God and I know that he sent his son. I'm
not exactly 100% sure on what the
relationship is because there are things
like Jesus was existing in God's form,
right? And so it's like what is that
form? Does that mean he was from him or
part of him or you know things like
that? And even as a baptized Jehovah's
Witnesses, there's things of the
Jehovah's Witness doctrine that I don't
believe.
>> Yeah.
>> Just purely off scripture, I'll give you
an example. I don't believe Michael the
Archangel to be Jesus Christ.
>> Amen.
>> You can you can disprove that in one
scripture in Daniel 10:13 where it says
that he was one of the foremost princes,
right? Michael was one of saying there's
many and there's nobody quite like
Jesus, right? Jesus is God's only
begotten.
>> Yep.
So, and I think a lot of Jehovah's
Witnesses are kind of at the point where
I'm at too because I've had many friends
that are like inactive or have left or
>> interesting
>> debating on things because we I think a
lot of Jehovah's Witnesses don't 100%
agree with Jehovah's Witnesses theology.
>> Wow.
>> And a lot of and and I think this is
true of a lot of a lot of different
religions. You know, if you're a Mormon,
there's certain things Mormons don't
believe in what they teach or even
Catholics, some Catholics don't believe
certain things that the Catholic Church
teaches. I guess the the inner struggle
that I'm having for me is because I was
born and raised as Jehovah's Witness,
saying things like Jesus Christ is part
of one God almost to me feels like
idolatry
>> because we're taught that no, all glory
goes to the father, Jehovah. Mhm.
>> And nothing goes to the son. Although
for me, I don't know how much see cuz
some people think unless you believe
right that Jesus is the father that
you'll die in your sins, right? In John
believe it's 8:24 it says that unless
you believe I am he. But I guess for me
that you know I don't know how much of a
salvational issue it is believing in the
trinity or not believing in the trinity
because I know if you honor the father
you honor the son and if you honor the
son you also honor the father.
>> Yeah. So let me ask you this. If if
Jesus is God, right, one in essence with
the father, the distinct person from the
father as his son, but also sharing in
the essence of the father, meaning that
he also is Jehovah or God by nature, if
that's who he truly is, would it be
honoring to reduce him to a creature
that Jehovah created?
>> Absolutely not. It would not be honoring
God.
>> Yep. So that's why having the true
Christ matters. It matters who you what
was the question he asked the disciples.
Who do you say that I am? Right.
>> Right.
>> That question matters. It is salvific.
If you have a false Christ, then you
have a false gospel. And if you have a
false gospel, then you have a gospel
that can't save.
>> I get I get what you're saying there.
But even his disciples there said,
"Well, you know, you're God's son, you
know, and and I wonder why." And maybe
it's because I'm a human and my lack of
understanding. I get the concept that
although there's three persons, they are
one God, one authority, one in nature,
one in essence. I can I can grasp the
trinity. It's not necessarily beyond my
grasp.
>> But what I wonder is why even for
thousands of years, this has been kind
of a debate amongst men. Why wouldn't
why wouldn't it be more clear to be able
to say, you know, this is the way that
it is? Because
>> brother, it has been, bro. If if you if
you look at church history, the the the
the church and early Christians, the
apostles and the early Christians, they
never once budged on the deity of
Christ. Never. Now, you do have fringe
groups that arise and you got heresies
that pop out and pop up and for
thousands of years, they've dismantled
them. They've they've disappeared. But
the one thing you always consistently
see standing are the trinitarians,
the ones who affirm the deity of Christ,
the one the the oneness uh and unity of
the father, son, and spirit,
>> right? Go ahead. Sorry.
>> I I get that. But what I what I'm
wondering is is why is it listed? Why
would it be something separate? You see
what I'm saying? Like we have the father
and the son. And like I'm a father
myself, you know? I have three kids. And
although my son is like me, he's not
necessarily me. We might be the same
nature like for example human right
>> but that doesn't mean that we're we're
one being cuz when I think of you we say
one god that I kind of I imagine it
being like almost like a what's that
three-headed dog that cbrus or whatever
you know that uh
>> I know what you mean
>> and and for me like I can get if it's if
we're saying the nature of God is is
like really they are separate persons
but like they're the same nature like
whatever nature God is like let's you
know what I mean that it's separate from
the angels nature. It's separate from
human nature and they're existing that.
But I don't I don't I don't know if it's
just because my mind is on earthly
things and I can't grasp heavenly
things, but I don't understand how
they're necessarily, you know what I
mean? Three three
>> distinct persons and one in Yeah. So, so
brother, so number one, I think that you
you need to be okay with the fact that
we will never ever
comprehend the the essence of God. God
is a completely completely different
dimension than us.
>> And I can agree I can agree with that.
Yeah. We can see his glory, right? Like
the glory of
>> Exactly. Exactly.
>> Exactly. So I think that one one uh way
to uh receive peace of mind about this
is to accept like literally this is what
God says in the book of Isaiah. He says
there's none like me. There's nothing in
creation that is unlike to me that is
like like unto me. Sorry. So, I
shouldn't expect for when we're talking
about the essence and nature of God for
me to be able to be like, "Yep, that's
that's like what it is." Or point to
something in creation and to to No, we
can't. He's completely other than we we
can't understand it. That's number one.
Number two is also once you understand
that, okay, yeah, cuz I'm not appealing
to mystery here. I'm not saying, "Oh,
yeah, you know, we won't understand God,
so just forget it. Stop asking
questions." No, that's not what I'm
saying. be okay with the fact that the
that that there's a mystery to godliness
as the Bible says that there's a mystery
to God's essence, but this is a truth
that we can apprehend. We won't be able
to fully comprehend it, but it's a truth
we can apprehend. We can hold on to. We
can receive. Meaning, this is how God
revealed himself in scripture. If this
is how God reveals himself in scripture,
I may not get it, but this is who he is.
This is who he is. you know, right?
>> I may not understand it fully. I got
questions. I don't know how that works,
but this is who he is, you know? So,
when you're talking about when the
scriptures talking about Jesus, like for
example, you talking about like uh as
Jehovah's Witnesses, you're taught that
all glory goes to Jehovah the father,
right? It's to the father, not to the
son and stuff like that.
>> Brother, that
is so opposite because Jesus literally
says this in John 17 verse one. He says,
"Now father, glorify your son that your
son may glorify you."
>> Right?
>> It it's mutual. There's a mutual
glorification. Jesus brings glory to the
father. The father brings glory to the
son.
>> Right? And yet Jehovah shares his glory
with no one.
>> And he shares his glory with no one.
>> Right? And so these are some of the
things that I've been struggling with as
a witness. as a long long time witness.
I kind of feel like, you know, if you
were if you were born and raised a
Muslim and you were taught all the
things of a Muslim, you pray five times
a day and you you know, you're taught
this is the truest revelation of God,
you know, and that the Bible is
corrupted and the Quran is the ultimate
revelation and all these other things.
Yet, yet to us it's very clearly false,
you know. And I sometimes I sit and I
think, am I the Muslim? Am I the man who
was raised to believe this certain way?
And because I've been taught this way
for so long that I failed to see the
truth.
>> And so I pray that God really show me
the truth because I'm going to be honest
with you. Even as a Jehovah's Witness, I
don't care if God is a trinity or if he
is separate. I just want to do what's
right in God's eyes.
>> Yeah.
>> That's all that really matters to me,
you know.
>> Yeah. None of that. Nico,
>> if Go ahead. I'm gonna cut you off. Go
ahead. And I was just going to say with
me being raised as Jehovah's Witness,
it's hard because we're drilled into our
heads so much that this is the way. This
is the truth. You know, there this is
the only way that you can, you know,
basically survive Armageddon or be have
a right relationship with God. And I
don't know, we've kind of lightened,
they've lightened their stances on that
a little bit,
>> but I, you know, I'm old school
Jehovah's Witness where I remember it
very much like you don't do this, you're
going to die.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, so in my heart,
>> I want to serve God the way that he
wants to be served. And so I'm trying to
figure out for myself what really is the
truth. And if not Jehovah's Witnesses
that I've been taught, then where and
who, you know? Mhm.
>> Yep. And I would say obviously it's
Christ in the scriptures as the
scriptures portray him. If you see that
the Watchtower and and this is what it's
like I'm just listening to you, bro. If
you see anybody, it doesn't matter who
it is. If you see anybody that is
opposing
clear scripture, they're opposing what
the scripture says. Their theology is
contradicting what the scriptures teach
and what the Holy Spirit has taught
through the apostles. then this is a
false doctrine. This is a false teacher,
a false entity. It's as simple as that,
brother.
>> Right.
>> I know I know it's harder obviously like
as you just described if you grow up in
something like this, it's hard to
disconnect from that and and and leave
that and cut that off and then fully
accept what the truth actually is. You
know, because you're you're in that that
state of kind of in an abyss kind of
like is this like is this am I doing
this right? and I want the truth, but
what is it, man? God has already worked
on your heart already to the point where
you said, "I want to know the truth. I
don't care if it's Jehovah's Witnesses
or I want to know the truth and I want
to do what's right." God honors that and
God will reveal himself to you and has
been pulling you and drawing you to the
truth of his son and the truth of the
Holy Spirit, the truth of himself. He's
been drawing you. It's very clear. It's
very clear. So you're because you're
you're you're able to see this stuff,
bro. You're able to connect the dots. I
I didn't I didn't even have to say, "And
Jehovah shares his glory with Noah." You
already connected that.
>> You already connected that. Here's a
Here's another verse. Revelation 5:14.
It says, "Worthy is the Lamb who was
slain to receive power and wealth and
wisdom and might and honor and glory and
blessing." Right? Now, if if the lamb is
No, notice what it says. it. Watch verse
13. I'll even put on the screen. It's in
it's in the New World Translation, too,
so it doesn't matter. But here's on the
screen here. Verse 13. And I heard every
creature, every creature in heaven and
on earth, and under the earth, and in
the sea, and all that is in them saying,
So, everything that has come into
existence that has a consciousness is is
is about to say this. This is what we
see. saying to him who sits on the
throne and to the lamb be blessing and
honor and glory and might forever and
ever. It just separated the lamb from
every creature in existence.
>> Correct? It's so there's no way that the
lamb is a creature too. Or else this
right here would be blasphemy to be
putting a creature with the father and
saying that they receive the same
blessing, the same honor, the same
glory, might forever,
>> right? I agree.
>> Yeah.
>> It's but it's there in plain writing,
you know,
>> plain writing.
>> And it's the Bible. And that's that's
one thing like even I've had arguments
with we have in the congregation men
that are called elders. These are men
that are very well-versed. They've been
proven to be, you know, true. And I've
had conversations with these elders
about some of these things like, hey,
you know, I'm starting to I'm starting
to see, you know, things like the
Trinity or, you know, these doctrinal
beliefs that we don't believe in, and
I'm starting to see see these things.
And the thing that kept bothering me was
when I talked to these elders, they kept
saying, "Well, you have to have faith in
the organization. The organization, you
have to have faith in the organization."
And I said, I don't care about the
organization. I care about Jehovah and I
care about God and I care about Jesus.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, it's I don't, you know, I want
because it got to the point where, you
know, I was a door knocker and I'm a
door knocker like everybody else that's
a witness.
>> We go to the doors and I was preaching
things that I started to not believe
myself.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, and I'm
>> Wow.
>> And I pray every day that God reveal
what the truth is to me. But I'm so
indoctrinated that I have that like I
said even to you know I tried like I it
took everything in me to just try to
pray to Jesus
>> because it feels like idolatry to me in
my heart although
>> you know I just want that truth of who
Jesus really is who God is and I want to
be able to be wherever that is. I don't
want to be the one at the end that's
like, "Lord, Lord, didn't I knock on so
many doors?" And
>> didn't we translate the Bible into a
thousand different languages? Yeah.
Thousand different languages. What?
Wrong. Because I add I see that we add
things like a God. The scripture doesn't
say a God.
>> It says he was God.
>> You know, it doesn't say every other.
And at least in our old version, it used
to put the brackets, which I felt like
was more honest than them taking the
brackets out.
>> Yeah. And I don't and to me it seems
like even that other scripture you read
to that young lady that was on here
where you know they put Jehovah there
instead of Jesus when it's clearly
Jesus.
>> And so to me you know it's really got me
questioning what their what their
intentions are. And one of the things
that really hit my heart lately is we
have what's called like the memorial. I
don't know if you've ever heard of it.
>> I've heard of it. Yeah. It's where it's
kind of like I guess you guys might call
it like communion or the Eucharist.
Yeah.
>> Where you partake in the bread and the
wine that Jesus commanded us to take of,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> Well, as a witness, we are taught that
only 144,000
partake. They have this heavenly hope
that's separate from an earthly hope,
right?
>> Mhm.
>> Which in the scriptures is very, very,
very vague. It only mentions the number
145,000, I think, once or twice in
Revelation.
>> About twice, I think. And uh you know
what started to bother me is somebody
said that that our version of like
communion was basically like a satanic
ritual because they read from the
scriptures out loud of Jesus command to
eat and drink and yet we openly and
publicly take that bread look at it
reject it and don't partake and pass it
to the next person. And when I read that
comment, I sat there and thought, is
this really what I've been doing where I
thought that I've been honoring Jesus
this whole time
>> and I've been rejecting the sacrifice
that he's given me, although I pray and
thank him for it every day.
>> Have I been publicly rejecting what God
asks me to do? And it's been on my heart
and my conscience to, you know, like I I
even like now I've come to the point
almost where I I want to celebrate
communion because I feel like I've
missed out and I don't want Jesus to
think that I'm rejecting him, but I
don't know where to go. I'm scared to
walk into any other churches. I'm sc
I've never been to another church in my
entire life.
>> I don't know, you know, there's certain
other denominations that I don't agree
with. You know, like I I've read Mormon
theology and that's out the window for
me. You know, Muslims, I've I've come to
think I don't think that's they're
anywhere near the truth. They deny Jesus
as well, right?
>> And I think that's ironically the same
thing that Jehovah's Witnesses, Muslims,
and Mormons, we all have in common is we
deny Jesus of who he claims to be, you
know. And our they've actually changed
our Bible translation further to where
it used to say before Abraham was, I
was. Mhm.
>> Where now it used to say that now it
says before Abraham existed I existed.
>> What
>> they changed it even further. And
there's a couple other scriptures. One
of the ones that bothered me is I was
watching a video of this um this Sam
guy. I know you've talked to him before.
And he was saying like there's a
scripture where they actually removed
where it says Jesus spirit and they took
that completely out of the Bible. And
that that just to me if you're adding
Jehovah where Jesus is and you're adding
Jesus where Jehovah is, you know, your
theology should change. The Bible should
not change.
>> Yeah.
>> The end of Revelation makes it super
clear that anyone that adds to it or
removes from it, you know, there's going
to be plagues and all kinds of things.
So, I fear for the governing body. And
I'm scared that the faithful discreet
slave has blood guilt that's reached the
heavens.
>> Oh, brother. They they they have guilt
that is that's going to be far beyond
our understanding with how many people
they deceive and continue to deceive.
The families they destroyed and continue
to destroy. And that's why it's up to uh
brothers like yourself and sisters like
your like yourself who come out of that
come out of that darkness. Scales fall
off and you guys see Christ for who he
is. Go ahead. It's funny that you said
come out of it because I keep in my mind
repeating the scripture and I don't know
if it's God or or what because I've
never been one to be like oh I hear the
voice of God or whatever but
>> you know I keep hear repeating the
scripture in my mind get out of her you
know she's fallen Babylon the great you
know like we used to we use this to
describe normally if you're Jehovah's
Witness what we call the world empire of
false religion
>> basically everybody else besides
Jehovah's Witnesses have it wrong this
is the Jehovah's Witness doctrine and so
To me, I'm hearing that for my own
religion now that for me it's get out of
her, you know, that you that you share
in her sins, you know,
>> because there's things where, you know,
we we do things like we don't take
blood, for example, and even in like our
own like watchtowers and like um our
young people ask, you would honor people
who've died who didn't take a blood
transfusion. And to me, I think it's
silly because even in the Mosaic law,
you you could you could break a law to
save a life.
>> Yeah.
>> Right.
>> So that's why Jesus often he healed on
the Sabbath and he did other things,
right? Because it's about at the at the
end of the day, it's ultimately about
love, right?
>> Like it's even love is even greater than
faith, you know? Like that's you know,
you could do all these wonderful things,
Apostle Paul said, but if you don't have
love, you're nothing.
>> You're nothing. And that's where what
bothers me, I guess, about being a
witness is we only have love for other
witnesses inside for each other.
>> Yeah.
>> Other than we we claim that it's love
that we go to their door, right? Like,
oh, we that's the whole what our what we
claim our motivation is, but really we
believe in a worksbased salvation, too,
which I've also proven somewhat to be
false in my case. I don't know if you
believe on works based salvation or not.
>> I don't.
>> Okay. So that's one thing that I've
proven to myself at least that was the
first thing that actually drew me to
Christianity I suppose was realizing
that wait a second there is nothing I
can do to earn salvation.
>> Yeah.
>> There's no amount of going to the
kingdom hall. There's no amount of field
service. We call it field service when
you go and preach the uh when we knock
on your door. We call it field service
for those listening that might not know.
>> There's no amount of field service.
There's no amount of praying. There's
not anything that you can really do to
gain salvation, which is very
contradictional to what Jehovah's
Witnesses believe. We believe like if
someone stops going to meetings, we're
like we pay attention, man. We're like,
you know what? We got to we got to go
knock on our brother's door and go
encourage him to get back on the get
back on the salvation train, you know?
And uh
>> that's deep, man.
>> And so I've been raised like this my
whole life, and I'm trying to figure out
Hey, maybe pray for me, please. like you
know that's
>> oh you you know we are we got thousands
of people in here that's praying for you
as we speak bro they're all praying for
you
>> please Chad pray for me that I come to
whatever the truth is whatever the truth
is is what I where I want to be you know
>> it sounds like you already left
Jehovah's left the watchtower in your
heart man
>> in my heart I have I really have you
know and it's
I'm trying to repent of the life that
I've lived but because I'm so
indoctrinated other I am so taught like
I'm telling you it is I was at school
when I was a kid being like you got to
be a Jehovah's Witness or you're going
to die you know like
>> yeah like
>> oh man
>> and so you know when you're drilled into
your head that this for a certain way
it's so it's like I've it's like I've
been waking up but it's also like
because I'm waking up I don't know where
to go you know like
>> yeah I'll tell you what email me so that
um and we can connect and Uh I know you
could tell me you can give me your your
personal information like when we start
talking and uh I can uh I can connect
you with some brothers and sisters and
uh we can help direct you in that way.
But yeah, we uh you you Yeah, you you
left you left the Watchtower Society and
I praise God for that. And now it's it's
just all about you growing and
submitting to Christ fully and trusting
in him, trusting that he will flush out
and burn off that baggage, burn off that
that Jehovah's Witness stench and make
you new. That's what Christ does. He
sanctifies us. And he's do going to do
the same for you. So you say yes to him.
You say yes to the Lord Jesus. Accept
him for who he is. What the scriptures
say he is. the divine son of the father,
one in essence with the father and the
spirit, perfectly united and
inseparable. You accept him for who he
is and he'll show you who he is and
he'll clean you up. He'll sanctify you.
>> Of course,
>> I really needed to hear that.
>> Yeah. Yeah, man. You the scales fall off
fell off your eyes. You see it already.
You see who he is. It was pretty clear.
That's why I I didn't I didn't have to
do much talking. The Holy Spirit has
already worked in your life. He's
already worked in your heart. I didn't
have to work hard at all here. I didn't
have to do anything. Notice you were the
one doing most of the talking. I was
listening. You were the one pre you.
Nico, you was the one preaching today,
man.
>> I'm sorry. I'm a certified yapper, bro.
I'm
>> No, no, no. Don't don't don't apologize.
You was spitting truth. You was
preaching what we call over here, Nico,
the gospel, man. That's what you was
preaching just now. And so, and you you
get it. And the only reason why you get
it is because the Holy Spirit has
already worked on you already. All you
have to do is trust in the Lord. Trust
in Christ for who he truly is. Put your
trust in him fully. And even with like
I'm not saying like you're going to be
all a gung-ho Jesus freak, you know? I'm
not saying that. But I'm like that'll
that'll he's going to do a work in you
and he's going to sanctify you and over
time you're going to see you're all this
stuff is going to fall off this these um
these feelings of blasphemy in your
heart. It's going to clean that out.
He's going to clean it all up, man. I
promise you. I promise you.
>> I appreciate that, brother. Thank you.
>> Just trust in him. Okay.
>> I'm trying, man. I'm trying every day.
>> Yep. Trust in him. Trust in him. Tell
him help you. Help your help your
unbelief. Help Hel help your struggle.
Tell him you believe in him. Tell him
you want to trust in him. Help me trust
in you. Help me believe in you fully.
Help me cling to you wholeheartedly and
cut off this uh cut from from the
Watchtow society. Ask him and and ask
him all the time and watch him do it.
Okay.
>> Appreciate that. I'm going to Thank you.
>> Can I pray? Can I pray with you?
>> Please do.
>> Yeah, for sure, man. Father God, we
thank you. We thank you for Nico. We
thank you for drawing him. We thank you
Lord God for working on his heart. We
thank you for working on his spirit. And
we thank you for bringing him to this
stream Lord God where you allowed him
the space to um express his faith and
express his doubts, express his fear um
and express his heart. And Lord God, we
just ask that you sanctify him, renew
him, create in him a new heart um and
renew a a a spirit within him, Lord God,
and waken him up to your power, to your
character, to who you truly are. And we
ask Lord that you protect him, that you
guide him, that you seal him, that you
uh cover him uh as he's going in this
journey. In Jesus name we pray. Amen.
>> Amen.
>> God bless. Don't forget, email me right
now so I'll have you at the top and then
we'll we'll be in communication. Okay.
>> I absolutely will, man. The prayer of a
righteous man is powerful.
>> That's right.
>> Thank you, brother. I appreciate it.
>> God bless, Nico. Appreciate you, man.
God bless. Peace. Isn't it amazing,
guys? Isn't it amazing what God does?
What God does. This ain't this ain't
Hey, this it ain't got nothing to do
with me, man. I'm just I'm just I'm just
here for the ride. This It is amazing
what the Lord does in people's lives.
It's amazing what he does in people's
lives. It's amazing how he works through
ministry, uses us as vessels, and he
speaks to us. He There's just no words.
God is faithful. God is faithful. God is
faithful, man. Yeah. And you y'all
wonder why this ministry is under so
much scrutiny and attack. This is why.
This is why, guys. Because lives are
being changed every single day by the
hand of God through this ministry. God
is being shown to be faithful and
trustworthy, merciful, and loving
through this ministry. That is why it is
under attack. That's why the enemy is
trying to distract. That's right. Satan
is pissed. He pissed off. Hot. Hot. He
wish I was doing a stream on something
else on some on some in infighting or
something. Nah, we we working. We are
working in our father's kingdom. Let's
see. JW Marvel Prince, you're on stage.
How you doing?
>> Fine. Can you hear me?
>> Yes, I can.
>> All right. Um, so brief brief background
Jehovah's Witness for I remember, excuse
me, 6 years old being at a convention. I
was an elder for 10 years, a ministerial
servant for two years before that. So,
one of the talks I would give would be
on Sundays would be about the Trinity,
of course, very anti-Trinitarian
mindset. Um, but now I had to pull the
brakes on that. So, I just So, man, I
don't know where to begin. So, I can
almost get on I can almost get on with
the tr excuse me, with the trinity. You
know, like the other caller said, I have
such an anti such a mindset that is, you
know, I used to give talks about the
trinity, right? I prepared the I was
also the watchtower overseer. So you
know you go deep on the the watchtower
studies and you conduct it that Sunday
morning you got to know it better than
the congregation and the governing body
the body the the elders would give you a
manuscript and my manuscript would be
about the trinity right
>> so but so now I mean a strange thing
happened I was at the park I met a guy
he prayed for me and my wife who's a
Jehovah witness too and um he asked me
if I ever heard of you
>> oh wow
>> yeah and I told him I had started
listening to you
>> praise which was very weird because he
uh put his hand on me, he prayed for me.
So, um so I can almost understand this
trinity a little bit, but it's kind of
um but he here are some things that that
kind of help me. So, first of all, do
you do you know Sharp's rule? The Greek
sharps rule, Granville Sharp his rule.
>> I I've heard of it. I don't remember it
though. I know I know what you mean. I
think
>> Okay, so that's
>> the great God and Savior, right? Great
God and Yeah. Mhm.
>> that Okay. It says our great God and
Savior Jesus Christ.
>> Yes.
>> So I can't man I can't get away from
that. That's that's kind of saying it.
See what I'm saying?
>> Yeah. It's that that one's plain as day.
>> Yes. Even though I come from this JW
mindset,
>> that scripture right there, there's a
couple. And Peter says it too.
>> Yeah. Yes, he does.
>> Peter says it too. He says that our he
talks about our God and Savior and then
you have Jesus Christ. So even anytime
you have the Greek word kai for and
connected by two nouns that next that
next word has to it has to apply to
them.
>> Exactly. Exactly.
>> Here here you have Jesus being called
great God and savior. And that right
there was one of the things that stopped
me. Now you also mentioned revelations.
You said revelations when they were
praying
>> and they were singing this song and I
mean so I read that right even witness
and they're giving worship up there.
>> Yes.
>> All of them are.
>> Yes. Yes. Yes. They're worshiping. Ain't
no doubt about it.
>> And they're singing it. Yeah. They're
they're all of them. So here's some of
my here's some of my drawbacks. Okay.
I'm going to use I'm going to use some
of my arguments when I was a Jehovah's
Witness and I was up on stage giving
talk. I'm going to use some of my best
some of my best arguments that I still
fight in my head. Okay.
>> Okay.
>> All right. And then you maybe we can
just talk them out if it's okay with
you.
>> That that's perfectly fine with me,
brother.
>> Okay. So, I would first get on stage and
I would say, you know, God is the
father, right? And they'd say, you know,
people say, right? Or if I was talking
to a trinitarian, this is how I'd corner
them. And I would say, have you ever
heard of a father and son being the same
age? So, I'm creating a distinction,
right? And they'd be like, no. See what
I'm saying? So, this is how I reason.
But then again, this is how the
watchtowwer kind we kind of teach you to
reason that way. And the average the
average person is going to make a
distinction between, okay, father's
older, son is younger. You It's just
that's just how it works. And then I
would say, okay,
>> yeah, and anytime you want to stop me,
go ahead. So, and then
>> I'm listening.
>> I would say, all right, I would say, all
right, let's go to John 14:28. And I
would ask you a question. I would say,
do you believe the father is God?
>> I'd say yes.
>> Yeah. You would say, yeah. Right. And
then I'd say and I say, "Okay, well, so
is Jesus saying that God is greater than
I am?"
>> And this I would corner people like this
and they would thought, "Oh, brother
Marll, he's such a good brother. He, you
know, he
was that warrior, huh?"
>> Yeah. Well, okay. Now, here now I I'm
not I haven't been into the Kingdom
Hall. I kind of stepped back. I'm
pumping the brakes on my I was those
people who was calling you defending the
Watchtower, the governing bodies, Jehosh
organization. I'll refer you to this
Watchtower. I would take the group out
and meeting for field service in the
mornings. I was the one to guide them
out to knock you on your on your door,
>> you know, stay late at the kingdom offer
or the elder meetings. I was doing all
that.
>> Yeah.
>> So now I'm pumping my brakes on it. I I
just
>> So So some of the points I just gave you
are some of the things that were in, you
know, I was taught all those years. Now
here's another one. Here's a thing about
the Trinity that I kind of, man, I kind
of deal with. So let's go to the famous
John 1:1. Okay. So in Greek, we're going
to we're going to look at from the Greek
standpoint. So you have haos, okay? The
god being with the logos, okay? And then
you have and the word was theos. So
here, and correct me if I'm wrong, John
is describing them in in the terms of
theoses. One is hotos. He's the god with
the Greek article, but he identifies the
word without the article. So he doesn't
identify the logos as the god. Does that
make sense?
>> Not really. What? So you're saying that
the word is not identified as the god
because there's no definite article
there.
>> Yeah. And that was what one of the
points that are the as usual witness.
That's one of the points that they make.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I'm familiar with their
arguments.
>> Okay. So what they're saying is that
John is not describing them as means of
persons. He's describing them as means
of does that make sense? One is the God
like you're the man who's with man. Does
that make sense? And like is it just
like saying what their their nature is
or their quality? Is that what it's
saying? Is that the
>> Yeah. Yeah. So he's saying that John is
describing the first theos hatos the
god. He's saying that the word was with
the god or hotos. But then when he
describes theos or he describes a logos
he simply describes him as
>> theos or gods. He doesn't he doesn't add
the the Greek article to that. So
they're saying it's not a separation of
persons, but they're being described as
gods. But one one is just God with the
with the Greek article and one god.
>> So silly.
>> Yeah. But you can see how that can can
can twist the person up, right?
>> Yeah. If they if maybe if they don't
know uh what John 1 says, even in the
Greek, Yeah. I I I mean, if if they're
completely ignorant, I can see Okay.
Okay.
>> If someone can get twisted up by that,
but like if you do any little reading
that that's e that's super easy to
destroy.
>> Yeah. Okay. You know.
>> Okay.
>> Would you uh so are these so you were
saying that these are some of the
arguments that you would run
>> and do you see do you see the flaw in
these arguments or do you want me to
deal with them?
>> Okay. You can help me with a little bit.
But now I'm thinking this is now me, you
know, years later separate just so what
I did was I stopped going to the Kingdom
Hall. I started reading the Bible by
itself. with no watchtowers, no, you
know, going jw.org and asking brother
Elder, another elder what he thought.
You know what I'm saying? I'm just
reading on my own.
>> Yeah.
>> So, one thing that I cannot deny, even
if you want to argue with the hotos in
the article,
>> the logos is definitely being referred
to as as theos God, that word that word
God is being applied to the logos.
>> Yeah.
>> So again, Jesus is being called God in
that verse.
>> Yeah. Literally. Now we can we can argue
the Greek and all this stuff but so
that's a simple thing that I'm kind of
working with. Now they're also saying uh
like Julius Mante and other scholars
they'll say that it is qualitative. He's
saying that the that they is a
qualitative nature of the word.
>> So it's so so the first one is referring
to God as a reference like as a person
the father when he says the word was
with the god.
>> Yes.
>> Right. It's talking about the person of
the father. And when it says that the
word was a god or or sorry the word was
god that's described or given the the
nature or quality of the word that he's
god.
>> Yes. That's right. That's right.
>> So and so that is a way and this is from
me reading just kind of reading over it
praying over it like okay so just
thinking um and now I'll say another
problem I have with with the with the
watchtower that kind of messed me up and
Johannes Gber have do you know who that
is?
>> No.
>> Okay. So, and so here's the thing about
him, and this is why I have a problem
with it. I mentioned it to other
Jehovah's Witnesses, and they don't,
they just goes right over their head.
>> So, when they searched out translators
to translate John one particular, and
you can go on jw.org and look up
Johannes Screber, they admit that he was
an oultist. He used his wife.
>> Yes. He used his wife as a spirit medium
to talk with the spirit world.
>> What?
>> Yes. And this is how they got John 1:1.
A God, they use it as an example. So you
got going, you got it going. And the one
thing that you do that I appreciate, you
go to like you'll pull up stuff out the
Quran, but you also go to jw.org. And I
like that because you can show Jehovah's
Witnesses.
>> Now, anybody with any sense of
spirituality who love for God or Jesus
is not going to be okay with that,
>> right?
>> I cannot defend the Watchtower on this
at all. This is very bad. We don't you
don't go to an oultist. especially like
this and use that. So once they real
realized that and you can see letters
back and forth online with the
Watchtower asking for the books and
stuff, people posted other elders like
myself who woke up and started posting
that stuff online said, "Hey, this is
what the Watchtower said
>> about this." So it's a fact. I mean,
it's it's undeniable fact. They actually
refer to this guy, Johannes Griever, as
a reference to John 11:1.
>> Wow. This guy, he's got his information
from the spirit world.
>> So, I got a problem with that. I'm
sorry. I can no longer defend it.
>> Wow.
>> I can no longer I can't knock on doors
anymore and defend
>> you know what I'm saying? Now, mind you,
this is this is the so-called governing
body, God's Jehovah's prophet here on
earth that is getting their information
from a cultist, someone who is
completely out of line with with with
God in scripture, who's going against
God, and they're getting their
information from him and putting it in
their in their Bibles. That's deep.
>> It is, brother. It is. And so, you know,
I was on stage. I'm defending them. I'm
knocking on people's door. Back in the
day, I would literally fight you to
defend my belief as Jew.
>> I was truly an apologist. You know, I
and that's why when I refer to
watchtowers and I refer to awakes by
years and months. For example, the April
1st, 1979 watchtower, page 31, you go
down a few paragraphs, it says that
Jesus is not the mediator for the great
crowd.
>> What?
>> Yes. See what I'm saying?
>> They denied that Jesus was the mediator
in their magazine.
>> So, let me explain it to you. Type in
mediator. Go on jw.org. Bro, if you know
more of these days, me and you should
just have a straight conversation about
what stuff you you need you need to you
need to equip me, man. Give me
everything. I'm a sponge, bro.
>> Okay, so here's the thing, brother.
Listen to this. And this is another
reason I have to pump the brakes. Okay,
they're telling us that according to
that watchtowwer and the and another
book called the piece, it's called a
peace of security. It has the words
peace of security on page 10, you will
see these expressions, but the
watchtower is a real good one cuz I go
into more detail. It's in what you call
the question for the reader.
>> And what they're saying is that Jesus is
only a mediator as far as prayer. In
other words, you can pray to him, but
he's not a mediator in the true full
sense of the word. As a matter of fact,
>> one of the sentences in that watchtower,
it says in a in a biblical sense, in a
true biblical sense, he's not the
mediator for those of the great crowd.
>> He he's only the mediator for 144,000
people.
>> What?
>> So, yes. So, so here's the thing now. A
mediator, and correct me if I'm wrong,
from a Christian standpoint, cuz you're
in Christianity more than me. I feel
like my heart is moving me towards
Christianity. Like, like the other guy
that he was talking to, everything he
was saying, I was like, "Yes,
>> but I'm I'm coming at it from an angle
of a person who was once teaching the
Watchtower to people." So, um,
>> wow, your brother, you're going to be
dangerous in the kingdom.
>> The Lord the way the Lord's gonna use
you is gonna be crazy. No, but actually
I I'm impressed with how he's using you.
>> Oh, thanks, man.
>> And and can I tell you one thing that
I'm happy for? I I pray for you and your
wife 10 times, brother. I'm going tell
you why. Because when I woke up, see my
wife, she she used to see me on stage
giving talks and stuff. And so I'm
pulling back trying I'm thinking, "Now
wait a minute. I'm seeing where Jesus
I'm seeing them giving honor to Jesus.
>> I'm saying that Jesus the God and
Savior. I'm seeing these things. My
wife's not seeing it. So, you and your
wife, you guys are on the same page,
bro. I I have one prayer that that um
that maybe my wife can wake up, too. You
know what I'm saying?
>> 100%. We'll all pray that for you, bro.
We We will all all the 3,500 of us in
here will be praying praying that prayer
until it happens, man.
>> Yeah. So, I'll finish my point. Yeah.
I'll finish this point about the
mediator, man. There's so much stuff I
could tell you, but so a mediator should
def when you go to court, right? the
mediator will stand next to you and go
to the judgment and kind of make your
defense, right? Yeah. This is what Jesus
does for us.
>> Yes.
>> But they're saying he doesn't do that
for you if you're not part of the
144,000.
>> That's tough.
>> He only does that cuz only there in the
covenant only they are born again.
>> Wow.
>> And so the average Jehovah's Witness is
not born of the spirit. They're not born
again.
>> Wow. Even an even an average Jehovah's
Witness is not born again. That is
>> no. And now do do the does does the
average Jehovah's Witness know this? Do
they know that the Watchtower teaches
that they're not even born again? It
doesn't matter. They're doing this going
door to door. They're, you know, putting
their time in. They're uh going to the
meetings, teaching their families,
raising their kids up in in in the
system. They they do they know that
they're not even considered born again?
>> So, but as you know the we're I'm sorry,
but our minds are twisted. Our our minds
are bent up on scriptures. We have
watchtowwer this and watchtowwer that in
our minds. So some of them know, some of
them don't. Um they feel like they don't
need to be born again because the
watchtower teaches
>> they teach that you just need to be in
association with the the anointed class.
>> Wow.
>> And and through benefits of being
connected with them. So they give the
example in the Bible where the uh true
Israelites would make it through but the
some proelites would join with them. So
the true people of God according to the
Watchtower are the anointed Jehovah's
Witnesses. Those men up in New York and
others who partake, they take the bread
and the wine. The average Jehovah's
Witness will not take the bread and wine
as the previous brother pointed out.
>> So when we leave the memorial, when I go
home at night, my wife and my and the
kids are asleep. I take the bread and
wine myself. They don't know that I do
cuz they they give you trouble for that,
you know.
>> Wow. Yo, you can get in trouble for
taking part in communion. Well, there's
one watchtower says that some people do
it because that they think they're
they're they're out of their mind.
They're crazy. But really, it's also so
many there there's a few Jehovah's
Witnesses and there's not that many on
this earth today that should be
partaking. So, they figure you're not
supposed to. Um I I'll I'll finish with
this and if ever you allow me back on
again,
>> you me you you and I we we're going to
talk. Look, you you got an email, right?
>> I do. It's Yeah. It's ex Marvel 19.
Yeah. Yeah, just just so my email is in
my description box.
>> Okay. All right.
>> Email me and we'll we'll exchange
contacts and you can teach me
everything, man.
>> Okay. I'm I'm going to finish this up
with with um the part about being born
of the spirit. Okay.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> So, I I I'll sum up with this. Okay. So,
Nicodemus was talking to Jesus, right?
And there's two things that he said that
stand out to me. Number one, no, you
must be born again to see and enter the
kingdom of God. You must be born again.
>> That's what he said.
>> Y
>> So the average Jehovah Witness says
we're not, bro. So we can't even see nor
enter the kingdom of God.
>> Wow.
>> That's a problem, bro. To be born to be
born from above, to be made new, to be
recreated, to be born again. And here's
the thing, and this is what we can talk
about. See, brother, I've never had that
that that experience that some people
say they felt the Holy Spirit come upon
them.
>> I've never had that, man. I've had
Watchtower in my head, but I feel like I
had to distance myself from the
Watchtower and the whole Jehovah's
Witness thing. And that's kind of rough
because, you know, this, you know, they
say, "Hey, brother Mel, you were a good
elder. We, you know, the the
congregation could use you." You know,
they would say things like that. But I'm
thinking, I can't can't do that
>> anymore. I can't defend this stuff no
more, man. There's so much stuff going
on.
>> Wow.
>> So before you go though, cuz man, you're
you're sparking my my my intrigue, man.
How how is it, you know, maneuvering
around this with uh you know, your your
your
um your family, your your friends at the
at the Kingdom Hall that you usually
fellowship at, the elders or brothers
that you usually you know, are
acquainted with. They know about you
pulling away and are do they treat you
the same? Like what? Tell tell me about
that a little bit.
>> Okay. So, a lot of them will just stop
speaking. They sh me. They a lot of them
stop speaking to me. The in-laws will
deal with me only because they want to
be around the grandkids somewhat. Yeah.
A lot of them will stop talking to you.
Some of they'll label you as bad
association and um they will say that
you gotten spiritually weak or you've
fallen away or you're an outright
apostate if you if I say too much. Um
but I never turned my back on God or
Jesus.
>> I I'll tell you one thing. I was
listening to you one night and you said
something, man. I got out of bed and I
got on my knees and I literally thanked
Jesus for it at that moment. I'll tell
you what you said real quick. You
brought out some scriptures in Psalms
and it talked about how Oh man, if I can
only paraphrase. It says, "Who is like
God?" It says, "Is there anyone like
me?" It was saying, it was using
language like that.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Psalm 113, I think it was. And
>> it was it was a couple. Psalms 89.
>> Yep. 89. Yep. 86. Yep. 86. That's right.
And it said like who who in the heavens
who's like God? So I was thinking, okay,
well, if this question is rhetorical,
Michael the Archangel can't can't be
none of this.
>> Exactly.
>> But in Hebrews, Jesus is the exact
representation.
He's exactly like him.
>> Exactly.
>> Another thing that messed me up for the
Watchtower is that in Isaiah chapter 6
and then John 12.
>> Yeah.
I said, "Wait, what?"
>> But but he calls him Jehovah.
>> Yes, he does. He sure does.
>> All right. Hey, man. Look, I could take
your time, too. We We know I'll call
back one. I mean, I I'll call I'll come
in one time again. Not when I'm driving
cuz I was driving
>> and we'll we can go over some Watchtower
history. How they believe that Jesus
appointed them in 1914. So, man, the
history. So, in 1914, they believe that
Satan was kicked out of heaven that
year. And then in 1919, Jesus chose them
out of all the religions. He chose he
chose them. So, we could talk about some
of their um catechism, some some of
their historic.
>> I would love to.
>> Yes. We'll talk about some of the
prophecies. Um the men's now living will
never die prophecy they gave.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I want I want to go through
all of it. I want to go through all of
it with Will we will we be able to show
stuff on the screen so that everybody
can see what we're talking about as
well?
>> Yeah. You know what we can do? We can
plan it to where we kind of have what
we're going to the the what we're going
to talk about and we can maybe do I mean
at work I use PowerPoint a lot. I don't
know if you use PowerPoint but we can
slides up.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That's fine. That's
fine.
>> Bro, let's cuz right now I'm kind of
random just going over things in my head
for I
>> Yeah, I know.
>> I didn't think you were going to call on
me. I said number one I'm a I said
number one I'm a former elder
>> and I don't know if he's going to want
to talk to me. You know, I didn't know
because and I know you got a lot of
people in here, but um no, those are
just been on my heart, man. Really?
>> Let let me tell you something right now.
And somebody said it in the comments
section that Avery planned for debates
today, but God planned for something
else. Literally, I I I planned to combat
the false beliefs and false religion,
but I didn't have to do it. You and even
the other brother right before you, you
guys have been coming up here preaching
the truth and sharing the truth. And you
guys are coming from an authentic
position from either ex Jehovah's
Witness or somebody who's like
transitioning out of it. Like well both
you guys are transitioning out of it. So
man, God brought y'all here to to do
this. It ain't I I obey the Lord, man. I
I'm I'm a sponge and I'm obedient. So
brother, thank you so much number one
for being patient and waiting as long as
you did cuz I saw you. You were waiting
for a while. Thank you for waiting. um
you blessed the stream. You um there's a
bunch of Jehovah's Witnesses that are
listening here. I'm I'm streaming both
here on YouTube and on TikTok. There's a
bunch of people listening, man. Bunch of
Jehovah's Witnesses are listening.
>> And so this is just even more
confirmation, my brother, that God is is
pushing me toward dealing with directly
Jehovah's Witnesses in this time right
now. It's just more confirmation. And
so, yeah, you and I, we're going to get
together. I'm going to get your number
when you email me. We can talk. We could
plan and we can do different sessions on
different we can have focused topics
where we do live streams on a focused
topic and and teach and and and expose
the falsehood.
>> Yeah, bro. The truth is a pillar. It's
unshakable. It's unchanging. And we
could talk about this old light how they
mis use and abuse Proverbs 4:18 every
time they get a false teaching old
light. Let's let's dismantle that verse,
bro. Let's dismantle that. No, let's
write down the verse and we will
dismantle
>> that false teaching. We're going to
shake the very
>> the very foundation of the watchtowwer.
>> Amen.
>> Let's do it, bro. Let's do it, man.
>> Let's do it. All right. Look, email me
right I mean right now. Do you hear me?
>> Okay.
>> It's in the description of of you you
look at the description on YouTube of
this of this video or any of my videos.
Hit the description. My email is right
there. Email me so we can we can get
this going. Okay. Okay, I'll do the A
man. I appreciate you, bro.
>> I appreciate you, dude. God bless you,
bro.
>> All right, man. Bye.
>> All right, brother Marll, man. Yeah,
that's that's that's going to be
awesome. That's going to be fun, guys.
Y'all y'all know me. I I get excited
when I'm learning new stuff, especially
when it's something that I am currently
interested in. Do you guys I know y'all
see it. Do you guys see what God is
doing? Y'all see what God is doing, man.
Man, the Lord is faithful. The Lord is
faithful. The Lord is good. I think I'm
gonna I think I'm going to wrap up here,
guys. I think I'm done. I think I'm
done. I'm I'm going to let this sit. I'm
going to let this rest. I don't I don't
need to do anything else. The spirit has
been working. I'm going to let the
spirit continue to just work and hover
over this and plant it in our minds. Let
us meditate on this. And we're going to
we're going to be we're going to be back
with a with another banger on Friday.
But man, what uh God is so good. God is
so good. Thank you, Lord. It's crazy
what he does. how he sends what how he
sends people and how he works through
people. And man, this was an amazing
stream. This was an amazing stream. I I
would not have I would I would not have
thunk it. Who Who would have thought?
Who would have thunk it, man? Yeah. Wow.